The observable universe is a big place that's been around for more than
13 billion years.
Up to 2 trillion galaxies made up of something like 20,000 billion
billion stars surround our home galaxy in the Milky way.
Alone scientists assume there are some 40 billion Earth-like planets
in the habitable zone of their stars. When we look at these numbers,
it's hard to imagine that there is nobody else out there.
It would change our perception of ourselves forever. If we found others,
just knowing that this vast place is not dead,
would shift our perspective outwards and could help us get over our irrelevant
quarrels. But before looking for our new best friends or worst enemies,
we have a problem to solve. What are we actually looking for?
[Inaudible].
In a universe that big and old,
we have to assume that civilizations start millions of years apart from each
other and develop in different directions and speeds.
So not only are we looking over distances of dozens to hundreds of thousands of
light years,
we're looking for a civilization ranging from cavemen to super advanced.
So we need a conceptual framework to enable us to think better thoughts that
make us able to search better.
Are there universal rules that intelligent species follow?
Currently our civilization sample size is only one.
So we may make incorrect assumptions based solely on ourselves.
It's still better than nothing.
We know that humans started out with nothing but binds and hands that could
build tools. We know that humans are curious, competitive,
greedy for resources and expansionist. The more of these qualities,
our ancestors had,
the more successful they were in the civilization building game.
Being one with nature is nice,
but it's not the path to irrigation systems or gunpowder or cities.
So it's a reasonable to assume that aliens able to take over their home plan is
also have these qualities.
And if aliens have to follow the same laws of physics,
then there is a measurable metric for progress.
Energy use is human progress can be measured very precisely by how much
energy we extracted from our environment and how we made it usable to do things.
We started with muscles until we learned to control fire.
Then we made machines that used kinetic energy from water and wind.
As our machines got better and down knowledge of materials expanded.
We began to harness the concentrated energy from dead plants.
We dug up from the ground as our energy consumption grew exponentially.
So did the abilities of our civilization between 1,820
15 population size had increased seven fold while humanity was
consuming five times more energy.
It's likely that this process will continue into the far future.
Based on these facts, scientists, Nikolai Carter,
chef developed a method of categorizing civilizations from cave dwellers to
God's ruling over galaxies. The Cotter chef scale,
a method of ranking civilizations by their energy use.
The scale has been refined and expanded on over the decades, but in general,
it puts civilizations into four different categories.
A type one civilization is able to use the available energy of their home
planet.
A type two civilization is able to use the available energy of vest star and
penetrate a system.
A type three civilization is able to use the available energy of their galaxy.
A type four civilization is able to use the available energy of multiple
galaxies.
These levels differ by orders of magnitude and it's linked pairing an ant
colony to a human metropolitan area to ans we are so complex and
powerful. We might as well be gods. So to make the scale more useful,
we need subcategories on the lower end. The spectrum.
There are times zero to type one civilizations,
anything from Hunter gatherers to something we could achieve in the next few
hundred years. These mice actually be abundant in the Milky way,
but a civilization that is not actively transmitting radio signals into space
might be as close as our nearest Stella neighbor, the alpha centaury system.
And we would have no way of realizing they exist,
but even if they transmitted radio signals,
can we do it might not be very helpful on an interstellar scale.
Humanity is practically invisible,
our signals mixed and over an impressive 200 light years,
but this is only a tiny fraction of the Milky way.
And even if someone were listening after a few light years,
our signals decay into noise,
impossible to identify as the source of an intelligent species today.
Humanity ranks at about level 0.75.
We have altered our planet. We've created huge structures,
mind and stripped mountains, removed rainforests and drain swamps.
We've created rivers and lakes and change the composition and temperature of the
atmosphere.
If progress continues and we don't make earth uninhabitable,
we will become a full type one civilization in the next few hundred years.
Any civilization that becomes a time,
one is bound to look outside because it's likely that it's still curious,
competitive, greedy and expansionist.
The next reasonable step towards transitioning to type two is trying to alter
and mine. Other planets and bodies.
This might start with outpost in space,
transition to infrastructure and industries near the home is move on to colonies
and end with terraforming other planets by changing their atmosphere,
their or position as a civilization expands and uses more and more
staff and space it's energy consumption scales with them.
So at some point they may embark on the largest project to lower type two
civilization can take on harnessing the energy of their star by building a
Dyson swarm. Once this mega structure is finished,
energy has become practically unlimited for molding the home system.
However they see fit. If they are still curious, competitive,
greedy and expansionist, and now have complete control over that home system,
the stellar infrastructure in place and the energy output of a star,
the next frontier moves to other stars,
light years away for a time to civilization.
The distance to other stars might feel like the distance between earth and Pluto
does to us today, technically within reach,
but only with immense investments in terms of time, ingenuity and resources.
This begins their transition towards type three.
This step is so far beyond us,
that it becomes hard to imagine what exactly these challenges will look like and
how there'll be solved.
Will they be able to find a solution to the vast distances and travel times of
hundreds or thousands of years,
will they be able to communicate and keep a shared culture and biology between
colonies light years apart all?
Will they split into separate type two civilizations,
maybe even different species?
Are there deadly challenges between the stars?
So the closer a species gets to type three,
the harder it becomes to fathom what it might actually look like.
They might discover new physics may understand and control dark matter and
energy, or be able to travel faster than light.
We might be unable to grasp that motives technology and actions
Schumanns are the ants trying to understand the galactic metropolitan area,
a high type two civilization might already consider humanity too primitive to
even talk to a type three civilization might feel about as light.
We feel about the bacteria living on the anthill.
Maybe they wouldn't even consider as conscious or our survival relevant.
We could only pray that they're nice gods,
but the scale doesn't necessarily. And here,
some scientists suggest there might be type four and type five civilizations
whose influence stretches of a galaxy clusters or superclusters structures,
comprising thousands of galaxies and trillions of stars. Ultimately,
there might be a type of Omega civilization able to manipulate the entire
universe and possibly others type Omega civilizations might be
the actual creators of our universe. For reasons beyond our comprehension.
Maybe they were just bored. As flawed as this classification may be.
This thought experiment is already telling us interesting things.
If our idea it is about the nature of species that form interstellar is sort
of correct,
then we can be pretty sure that there are no civilizations of type three and
beyond near the Milky way,
their influence with an unlikely hood be so all encompassing in that technology
so far above our own that we couldn't miss them.
The galaxy should flash with our activity in thousands of star systems,
we should be able to see or detect that artifacts or movements between different
parts of our empire.
Even if a type three civilization did exist in the past and died a mysterious
death, we should be able to detect some of the remnants of our empire,
but when scientists logs, they didn't find remnants of harvested stars,
decaying, mega structures, or scars of great interstellar Wars.
So they're very likely not out there and never were in a sense.
This is very sad, but also very reassuring.
It leaves the galaxy to us and others similar to us.
So the most promising civilizations to look for,
maybe somewhere in the spectrum from type 1.5 to type 2.5,
they wouldn't be too advanced to understand them and their motives.
They may have finished their first mega structures and they might be in the
process of moving stuff between stars and transmitting enormous amounts of
information into space by an accident or on purpose.
They would probably also look to the stars and look for others. Then again,
maybe we've got it all wrong.
Maybe progress to type two does not mean expanding outwards and
humanity is still too immature to imagine.
Otherwise for now, all we ready know is that we haven't seen anybody.
Yes, but we've only just started looking
until we finally find friendly,
super aliens and can ask them to explain the rules of the universe to us.
Most of us have to make do with learning stuff ourselves,
whether you're going back to school, leaving home for the first time,
or if you're just entering a new phase in your life,
our shop is stocked and ready for all your back to school needs,
notebooks and notepads to organize your work stickers and monks to make things
look nice,
lots and lots of posters to turn your dorm or room into an inspiring Oasis of
knowledge. We have new shirts and for the first time eight codes,
Cassata earth sweater.
All of these products are designed and produced with love by the codes.
Cause out merge burbs are merges the easiest way to support what we do and keep
our videos free for everyone. Thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].